we Spartans descended from Hercules
himself thought never to retreat never
to surrender taught the death in the
battlefield is the greatest Glory he
could achieve in his life Spartans the
finest soldiers of the world has ever
known it's quiet
now the GES from the
Blackness be afraid Sparta will burn to
the
ground the s and nations of the Persian
Empire descend upon you what must the
king do to save his world instead ask
yourself what should a free man
do you threaten my people with slavery
and death this is
madness Magnus this is
sp we will stand and
fight
the new age has
begun the age of
freedom and all will know the 300
spots give the last breath to defend
it
spots tonight we died in
hell
give them
nothing but take from
them
everything we're in for one wild
night